la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
c'est un peu comme un chantier de
construction il faut rassembler les bons
outils il suivre le plan sur papier on a
pensé à tout mais immanquablement des
imprévus surviennent le gouvernement le
goût n'y a pas échappé et ce dès le
début de son mandat
[Applaudissements]
à peine un mois après l'élection de la
caq trois mauvaises nouvelles
économiques ton coup sur coup
rona faire neuf magasins ne sais pas
quoi vous dire bombardier supprime 2500
emplois c'est pour la première fois
qu'on compense un mauvais quart d'heure
si coup quitte le québec rationalisation
des activités de l'entreprise
est-ce qui va renégocier l'entente avec
bombardier pour protéger nos emplois
alors qu'il déchirait sa chemise dans
l'opposition pour que le gouvernement
couillard sauf des emplois une fois au
pouvoir françois legault constate qu'il
a les mains liées
lui aussi s'assurer tout faire pour pas
perdre d'autres sièges sociaux mais
l'oeil est trop tard il faut regarder en
avant
le nouveau premier ministre est
confronté à son premier test de réalité
on va essayer d'en garder ses pas moyen
de convaincre l'entreprise de renverser
cette décision là mais c'est
l'entreprise en bout de ligne qui va
prendre la décision la fermeture de six
corps rattrape à boston où il souhaitait
parler d' échanges commerciaux pour sa
première mission économique en sol
américain
quelques jours plus tard sa rencontre
avec le premier ministre d'oxford est
marquée par les compressions dans les
services français en ontario
françois legault se retrouve à défendre
la langue française plutôt que
d'inventer l'hydroélectricité du québec
imposé son programme n'est pas toujours
une mince affaire
lui dit on est un des deux peuples
fondateurs du canada
c'est un conseil des ministres paritaire
culte et françois legault ne peut
compter que sur une seul ministre avec
de l'expérience larguerait de blaye tous
les autres en sont à leurs premières
armes
ce que ce que j'entends de ce que vous
me dites c'est que vous voudriez qu'on
perde notre engagement envers
l'environnement
le battage médiatique est difficile
c'est quoi le fonds vert comment est-ce
que vous résumer ça c'est une excellente
question difficile particulièrement pour
la ministre de l'environnement
marie-chantal chasser à tel point que
françois legault ne peut plus la garder
dans son équipe
marie-chantal commencé à bien comprendre
c'est d'aussi jeune ingénieur d'une
femme d'affaires mais la partie
communiqué 5 les journalistes s'étaient
dit il la remplace par le député benoit
charette
le conseil des ministres n'est plus
paritaire le premier ministre ait forcé
d'accorder une importance particulière
au ministère de l'environnement un enjeu
que le gouvernement caquistes se fait
imposer par la population on a bien reçu
le message la population pendant la
campagne on doit en faire plus pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
le premier ministre devrait se
retrousser les manches et agir pour
réduire nos émissions
les partis d'opposition doute de sa
volonté de s'attaquer aux problèmes de
l'environnement et le talent sommes
pratiquement tous les jours sur cette
question clairement un pic jamais les
québécois souhaitent que l'environnement
soit une priorité pour le gouvernement
c'était différence pour l'enjeu le plus
important de notre époque n'est plus
tenable
le conseil des ministres néophytes de
françois legault l'obligent à se mettre
à l'avant scène
les parents qui ont un deuxième un
troisième enfant vont recevoir 500 $ de
plus c'est la première fois qu'un
premier ministre présente une mise à
jour économique aux côtés de son
ministre des finances
il annonce une nouvelle allocation pour
les familles les surplus de 4 milliards
de dollars remplissent mes coffres du
gouvernement françois legault lui même
éprouve quelques problèmes de
communication des augmentations prévues
et qui vont être mis en fit une
vingtaine de jours après sa victoire il
annonce la suspension des hausses de
salaires des médecins spécialistes avant
de parler de gel ou quoi que ce soit je
le redis on a besoin de bien comprendre
les attentes
une semaine plus tard le président du
conseil du trésor christian dubé réside
finalement imposé le gel salarial mais
pour ses premiers pas le gouvernement le
groupe bénéficie d'une certaine période
de grâce
je suis très heureux aujourd'hui
d'assurer la succession de monsieur
couillard je tends la main à l'ensemble
des chefs parlementaires dont je serai
le cadet les partis d'opposition sont
affaiblis libéraux et péquistes
travaillent à la reconstruction de leur
formation
pendant que québec solidaire est occupé
à gérer sa croissance
françois legault pour fait aussi d'une
année pré-électorale à ottawa il ne
s'entend pas avec justin trudeau sur son
plan d'immigration menée sur la
légalisation du cannabis mais le
gouvernement fédéral évite la
confrontation lors du redressement
national en éducation a sonné dans son
discours inaugural le premier ministre
fait de l'éducation sa grande priorité
durant les cent premiers jours le
gouvernement le godet pose quatre
projets de loi
le projet de loi numéro 1 une langue
pour revoir le mode de nomination à
l'upa qui à la sûreté du québec l'autre
pour resserrer l'encadrement du cannabis
et un troisième pour instaurer un taux
unique de taxation scolaire le dernier
projet de loi déjà adoptée reconnaît
officiellement le parti québécois et
québec solidaire l'assemblée nationale
ce qui leur donne plus de moyens pour
faire leur travail
[Musique]
en lune de miel avec bien des québécois
le gouvernement le goût a préféré
repousser à l'année 2019 son projet de
loi le plus des tiges yeux celui sur la
laïcité de l'état
un dossier sur lequel plusieurs de ses
prédécesseurs se sont cassé les dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]